what's going on guys this is rob and we
are remastering jonathan hickman's
fantastic four because as always with
the old videos i used to do that just
weren't very interesting we go back and
redo them in order to make them more
interesting but this story is the
fantastic four story and i wouldn't be
surprised if the marvel cinematic
universe version of the fantastic four
film borrows heavily from this run it's
one of the most phenomenal runs ever
written ever in the history of the
characters now this takes place during
dark rain dark rain is a story that took
place after the events of secret
invasion we're not going to spoil it
because we are going to start covering
secret invasion on sundays but the thing
behind this is that this basically picks
up initially with franklin richards and
valeria now the thing behind this is
that franklin and valeria are the kids
of reed richards and susan storm for
those of you guys who saw doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness and you were
super hyped up when reed richards in the
illuminati said that he has kids of his
own that's because he was referring to
franklin and valeria so valeria is as
smart as reed richards is and in fact
valeria richards reed richards and
doctor doom usually kind of trade the
number one spot in the marvel universe
for the smartest person in all of
existence right the smartest person in
the universe itself the thing with
franklin richards is this is a kid that
can alter reality on a universal scale
the kicker to this is that a long time
ago basically he had mental blocks put
in place so we couldn't consciously
utilize the full totality of his power
but the thing behind this is that this
basically picks up with them essentially
moving back to the baxter building so
not a great big huge deal then of course
everybody sort of get their things
sorted out and trying to figure out what
they're gonna do and you know getting
things moved and you know johnny storm
is lamenting the fact that he lost the
phone numbers of all these chicks in new
york who were just hot and single and
you know looking to get some of that
johnny storm action
but of course reed richards is supposed
to be helping but when they get down to
his lab he's actually working on this
gigantic bridge now the cool thing about
this as reid explains it is the bridge
allows him to look into alternate
realities so for those of you guys who
saw our initial coverage of jonathan
hickman's fantastic four we actually
didn't include this so we're basically
including it here in order to make it
all all make sense for those of you guys
who are following or who have seen my
videos on jonathan hickman's avengers
and new avengers when reed richards
creates the bridge or uses the bridge to
basically see the illuminati in other
realities to see how they fare against
the incursions this is where it starts
this is where he comes up with the idea
for the bridge in the first place now
the kicker to all this is that you
actually have hammer agents that are
coming to the to the backstreet building
for the fantastic four now the thing
about this and that's what's so funny
here these guys come busting into this
place but what's also kind of wild is
that that at the same time that happens
reed richards basically enters the
bridge into what's kind of this nexus of
realities if we want to call it that
this sort of place where he can see or
at least experience pretty much every
universe that exists out there and so
it's one of those things where when the
hammer agents break in the fantastic
four do not initially know that it's
happening but once they start to realize
that it's happening when power is
basically taken down in the building by
the hammer agents you have sue you have
johnny and you have ben who essentially
go you know get on an elevator to go
down to the first floor and then of
course it shuts down what that means is
it leaves franklin and valeria
unprotected now here's the thing about
this that segment of the story when it
comes to reid and and ben and johnny
they're gonna actually end up being
forced through different realities
themselves their story is not overly
important because the realities aren't
really all that interesting but what we
end up doing here is basically switching
over to franklin richards when he draws
two toy guns on the hammer agent so the
hammer agents think he's adorable they
think he's super cute
they have no idea what he's what they're
messing with they have no idea what
they're messing with here right they
have no clue what what they're doing
with this kid now nothing crazy happens
right like what's actually going on is
behind franklin valeria with all her
intelligence is actually putting
together a phone but she makes it look
like a gun and then she points it to the
hammer agents they basically issue a
summons and essentially saying that like
norman osborne's gonna be here tomorrow
uh you guys better meet him when he
arrives something along those lines more
or less but the important thing here is
switching over to read this is cool
because this is when we get to see all
these different realities that exist out
there the main motivation going on here
with reed richards is that he looks back
over the events of civil war he looks at
the formation of the illuminati he looks
at secret invasion and he sees it all as
being his fault and the reason for this
isn't necessarily because it is but it's
because reed richards is so incredibly
intelligent that quite literally the
things that he comes up with can make or
break not just the world but even the
universe itself the guy is just
incredibly capable when it comes to
technology and so what he does is he
tells this machine this device that he
has show me how many viewable realities
similar to our own enacted some type of
superhuman legislation during roughly
the same period of time that we did and
he's basically told there's about 12 and
a half million realities where that's
the case then he says okay of those
realities how many resulted in a
conflict within the meta-human community
basically civil war and he's told three
million of them and he's like okay of
those how many resulted in a peaceful
resolution and the answer he's given 418
of all the realities that existed out
there 12 12 and a half million basically
passed legislation and saying
superhumans have to register their
identities with the federal government
three million of those basically
resulted in a civil war event and 418 of
those civil war events ended peacefully
right the other remaining however many
million basically ended up in all the
superheroes being killed in some form or
fashion and that's one of the things
that happens right here right like we're
literally told case study earth 155 in
this reality reed richards and hank pym
initiated the registration act pym died
of an aneurysm two days after the law
was enacted and while there was one
major skirmish reed notices and says i
was able to convince everyone of the
necessity and sanctity of appearing to
be accountable to human law to man-made
law right so literally it was reid
richards who was able to talk everybody
down in that alternate reality case
study earth 3490 this basically had the
exact same thing it was actually iron
man who's a woman cue all the guys that
hate chicks a position of power
complaining but it was iron man who was
a woman basically marrying uh captain
america right like it's literally all
those different things right case study
earth one 1 789 0002 that the 50 state
initiative program was successful
because a serum was developed to give
abilities to everybody who wanted them
now for those of you guys who don't know
the 50 state initiative was a was a
concept that was basically built or
developed by reed richards and hank pym
and tony stark that was kind of an
answer to the superhuman registration
act that in order for superheroes to
continue functioning what would happen
is there would be a superhero team in
all 50 states and they would be
answerable to the federal government now
the initiative was also a comic book
line and it was basically superheroes
training the next generation of
superheroes it was maul's attempt to
kind of build out the idea or the
concept of like young avengers and like
young x-men and that kind of a thing it
was okay it wasn't all that great but
another example is earth 26 where reed
richards takes away everybody's
superpowers across the board earth 1735
was a reality where basically the
superhuman registration event went
through right that legislation became
law because there was no one like
captain america to stand in the way
because captain america hadn't been
discovered yet right he was still frozen
in ice at the time that registration
went through but the reality here is
reed richards notices a kind of constant
through all these different universes
that he's looking through right he
notices one thing that never changes in
all the instances where there was some
peaceful resolution to the civil war
event it was him acting alone it was not
having any involvement from hank pym or
tony stark or anybody else it was him
relying on his own intelligence and
that's one of those instances where
basically what reid is saying here is
civil war could have potentially
happened differently had it been some
scenario that it unfolded where there
had been no tony stark and there had
been no hank pym because they wouldn't
have been able to get him to change his
mind on certain things and so as a
result of that he's like okay let's see
if we can't take a look around any more
of these different realities and so
following that he takes his
investigations a step further knowing
how civil war could have ended then the
question becomes how do things exist in
other realities when it comes to members
of the illuminati right 67 worlds where
the illuminati formed and things went
peacefully because the reality is that
when it comes to the illuminati and
marvel comics they usually create more
problems than they solve hence the
reason why they were the reasons why
secret invasion happened in the first
place had it not been for them secret
invasion never would have taken place so
it's one of those things where like they
usually create issues because as smart
and intelligent as they are the reality
is that their goals exceed their grasp
and so they end up just creating issues
but he says i learned that only 67
earths that had suffered through through
both a superhero civil war and the
creation of the illuminati would
actually know peace so of those 418 now
there's only 67 that have both a civil
war and an illuminati event where things
don't go south he says the truth of the
why was even more disturbing than the
evidence and he says case study earth
976 this world's reed richards convinced
tony stark that if they had the larger
interests of the planet in mind then
they should include members who could
protect it best the difference here and
this is one of the more significant
things is that when the illuminati was
originally formed it was reed and it was
tony stark and it was doctor strange and
blackbolt of the inhumans which i don't
understand why because he sucks and
professor xavier of the x-men so on and
so on right they were all brought
together because it was believed they
were the ones best suited to basically
lead the illuminati and to keep the
world safe because they had kind of
taken it on their shoulders we're the
leaders of some of the most significant
teams or were the most intelligent
people or we know more about magic than
anybody else but we have decided that we
are the best decision when the reality
here is that reed kind of harbored these
doubts and saying okay are we really the
ones best suited to be making this
decision should it only be us or if
we're looking to actually safeguard the
world as a whole should we bring in
people like dr doom and and magneto and
so on and so forth but that never
happened however in this world it seemed
like it did now there's another instance
right case study earth 231 the world's
reed richards avoided all future
calamity caused by the illuminati by
eliminating them at the point of
inception literally the instant the team
came together and they said okay guys
let's do this reid was like no this was
a bad idea and just just killed him all
on the spot and again he dies a little
bit further here in saying okay like how
far reaching are the effects of the
things that the illuminati did for
example learning about the beyonder and
different things like that so he studies
the beyonder momentarily and comes to
this realization on earth 538 after
being confronted the beyonder chose to
remake the world into a place where he
was worshiped and adored that this earth
knew peace as all heroes and villains
were transported to a reimagined battle
world and that war was not so secret
there was another reality right case
study earth 2819 where the beyonder
destroyed the world and then recreated
it with no human life on it whatsoever
and then created one man and one woman
and let it basically just kind of start
from scratch he effectively became god
it's one of those wild things right it's
him just looking at all these different
realities here but what we end up doing
is basically transitioning while reid is
kind of going through all these
different universes we transition to the
next morning when franklin richards
wakes up alongside valeria to the
realization that norman osborne is on
his way to the baxter building now those
of you guys who have read about franklin
richards and you know how powerful
franklin richards is i'm sure you've
seen this moment for those of you guys
who don't know anything about franklin
you're going to get what's probably the
most interesting and unique aspects of
reality warping but the thing behind
this is that when norman osborne arrives
initially valeria and franklin just kind
of play doc right this kind of plays
silly and they're like well i mean you
know like uh you can't go see them right
now you know they're really busy and
that kind of a thing and valeria sort of
puts on this little bit of a show and so
on and so forth but ultimately she ends
up leading norman osborne to franklin
richards right she's like you're not
going to meet my dad you're going to
meet him and then of course franklin
richards has like a mask on and that
kind of a thing and it's kind of funny
because he's literally just got like
these toy guns right these little these
little pop guns you know at his disposal
but again it's a really really hilarious
moment because knowing who franklin
richards is and knowing what he can do
this is a pretty dangerous situation to
be in but ultimately we kind of switch
back to reed richards for a moment and
after having gone through all these
different universes reed richards comes
to the realization that he really is the
only one who can fix everything right
he's the only one that can solve the
problem of everything that it all
basically comes down to him and the
question is if it does come down to him
then how does he fix everything right
how does he solve everything and so what
he does is he basically says okay like
it's time for me to fix this and he
ultimately just shuts the machine down
because the intention and the purpose
behind it was to quite literally just
observe other realities there was no
motivation to it but once power and
everything is restored and once reid
richards is done and all that kind of
stuff everything sort of goes back to
normal to a degree in the sense that
susan and johnny and ben end up coming
back to the main marvel universe reed
richards basically emerges and then
literally they're caught up to you by
franklin and valeria who were just
running from norman osborn who's
basically shooting at him and then like
once the fantastic four arrive on the
scene they're like get away from our
kits right here's the important thing to
understand here at this moment norman
osborne normally he's the green goblin
this guy's the director of shield right
this guy is well at least used to be
shield this guy's a big hitter he's got
the full might of the federal government
behind him so you can't simply just
assassinate him or you can't just
arbitrarily kill him and even if he
could it's not really something the
fantastic four would do but it's one of
those things where susan storm literally
puts up force field basically locks
norman osborne in place with them and
then blocks all of his forces on the
outside so none of them can get in and
then in turn it basically turns into a
conversation between reed richards and
norman and it's one of those things
where where norman's just kind of like
okay here's the deal right like this is
not done like you guys have me on the
ropes sure you got me back into a corner
whatever but i'm gonna come back right
like my word is law now like this is
like the the registration act everything
that i'm doing here it's
incontrovertible it is directly like i
have the full backing of the federal
government there's nothing you can do to
stop me outside of basically going
underground and becoming outliers or
something along those lines and so at
the end of the day when he says like
this is not even close to being finished
the responsive read is no it's not but
you're leaving right now and one of the
things that happens is that as reed
turns to walk away norman osborne pulls
a gun to shoot him and there's just this
bow right this gunshot that goes off and
then you literally have franklin
richards standing there with a smoking
gun that's not real and that's the power
of franklin richards this kid can alter
reality right so what this kid basically
did was fire a real bullet out of a fake
gun that's literally what he did now
this is the importance behind this this
is one of the things that's going to be
ridiculously important over the course
of our coverage of jonathan hickman's
fantastic four there was an old
fantastic four story way back in the day
when franklin richards was messing
around with a rubik's cube trying to
solve it and getting really really
frustrated or playing with some kind of
toy or something like that there was a
tv commercial that came on in the
background that said when are you going
to grow up and franklin richards
subconsciously aged himself into an
adult when the dust settled and
everything about went back to normal and
then reed richards figured out what was
going on he realized okay so franklin
has the ability to alter reality on a
universal scale and so we put mental
blocks in place so franklin couldn't
consciously use his powers but over the
years in marvel comics those powers have
manifested right in the aftermath of the
onslaught saga basically when franklin
richards resurrected all the dead
superheroes he literally brought them
back to life and put them in an
alternate reality to give you guys
perspective here it's like during the
events of infinity war and avengers
in-game right thanos snaps his fingers
he blinks out half the life in the
universe but franklin richards survives
so like franklin richards if he existed
in the mcu at the time basically
resurrects everybody who died and then
puts him in an alternate reality that he
carries around in the form of a blue
ball that's how powerful this kid is but
remember the mental blocks are in place
he can't really access his power and so
as a result of this you basically have
this realization like okay franklin's
powers like this is this is kind of wild
now one of the things that i want you
guys to notice here is that because of
all the commotion and all the panic and
all the chaos people don't realize
franklin has a toy gun they don't
realize it's a toy and in fact johnny
storm takes the gun away from him pretty
quickly and so there is a kind of
offhanded remark that johnny storm has
as they're walking away where he's like
i don't understand it right it's a fake
gun like what in the world happened but
that's the thing like they don't realize
franklin's powers have manifested in
that moment and no one's really giving
it any thought they will
but it's one of those things where susan
asks reid like did you get everything
you needed from that bridge right did
you get what you needed and the
responsive read is yes i basically did
and she's like then destroy the machine
now the funny thing about this is that
what had happened is that where reed had
basically said yes i got everything that
i needed nothing else had happened reed
had lied because in that moment when he
went to shut the machine down he was
like wait right he's like i have a
question and so the machine's like
what's your question and he's like one
final projection eliminating all
previous parameters so not taking into
account civil war or secret invasion or
the formation of the illuminati or
anything like that how many other
instances have there been requiring
similar technology to your own how many
other bridges have been built and the
system starts processing it and it says
141 and that's literally when this these
individuals these beings back behind
this uh really within the bridge itself
up here to read richards and it's one of
those things where where literally he's
like you know nothing nothing really
happened here right nothing nothing
significant happened you know what's
cool you know that's literally when he's
telling susan like i'll shut everything
down you know it's not a great huge deal
but the reality is a lot of things
happen that one of these voices or one
of these beings talking to reed says let
me guess you want to fix things and the
other one another one says we can help
you with that and when reid asks who are
you their response is we're just like
you read right and we'll be here waiting
for you when you're ready but don't take
too long there's no telling how much
worse things could get and so reid
ultimately powers off the machine and
the irony behind all this is that where
he told susan yes i'll break the machine
down he openly admits yeah you know i
told i did exactly what i told her i
would do i took the machine apart i
broke the machine down and then i put it
right back together again with that
being said guys the rest of hickman's
run this is probably the slowest part of
the run to be honest this and maybe the
next one is probably the slowest part
after that it takes off in an instant
right it just it goes from zero to 60.
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace